Bonjour, vous êtes déjà 3 millions d'abonnés à ma chaîne YouTube, je n'ai qu'une seule chose à vous dire:
Merci beaucoup.
♪ Merci Beaucoup, Merci Beaucoup, Merci Beaucoup, merci Beaucoup ♪
Voilà c'était juste un petit message pour vous les abonnés.
♪ Les abonnés, les abonnés, les abonnés, les abonnés ♪
Mais vous êtes qui exactement?
♪ Mais vous etes qui? mais vous etes qui ? mais vous etes qui ? mais vous etes qui ! [Le mec à droite perd sa moustache]
D'accord donc y a carrément des danseuses, c'est "fiou".
♪ Y'a des danseuses, Y'a des danseuses, Y'a des danseuses, y'a des dan[...] ♪
STOP STOP STOP STOP !!!!!!!!
♪ top top top, yayayayayayayayaya
VOUS SORTEZ D'ICI, MAINTENANT, VOUS SORTEZ D'ICI !!!!!!!!
Vous parlez pas français en fait?
Couci couca, couci couca (Moyen)
Bon bas heu... Puisque vous êtes là...
Merci beaucoup les abonnés (Chant)
(SAPRISTI) Sous titres : Cassandre COMES